الجانب الروسي يؤكد صده لهجمات في دونيتس
وكذلك فيزا
نعم عبد القادر صدلي هجمات متعدده ولكن
التطور الابرز الذي تحدثت عنه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قبل قليل حين قالت انها
صدت محاوله لاستهداف احد الزوارق التابعه
لاسطول البحر الاسود هذه الحادثه ليست
الاولى في اقل من شهر هذه هذا الاستهداف
الثاني لسفن تعمل على في تلك المنطقه قبل
نحوي في الرابع والعشرين بالاحرى من ايار
مايو حصل استهداف لايفان خورس وبعد ايام
تم سحب تلك السفينه اكدت وزاره الدفاع
حينها انه لم يلحق بها اي اضرار اليوم
استهداف اخر او محاوله استهداف اخرى لاحد
هذه الظوارق التي تراقب عمل وضمان ترك
ستريم وبلوس ستريم هذه المسارات للغاز بين
روسيا وتركيا تحدثت وزاره الدفاع عن ان
هذا الزورق لم او هذه السفينه لم تصاب باي
اذى قد شملت عمليه الاستهداف سته زوارق
اوكرانيه مسيره وهذه وهذه السفينه مستمره
بالقيام بعملها لنستمع الى ابرز ما قاله
ايغور كناشنكوف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه حول هذا الاستهداف
اليوم عند الواحده والنصف بتوقيت موسكو
اقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه على محاوله فاشله
للهجوم على السفينه
التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود والمكلفه
بمهام مراقبه وتامين خطي انابيب الترك
ستريم
حيث استخدمت في محاوله الهجوم سته زوارق
مسيره دمرت جميعها لم تسجل اي خسائر ولم
تصب السفينه باي اضرار اثناء الهجوم نفذت
طائره مسيره تابعه للقوات الجويه
الامريكيه مهمه استطلاع في المجال الجوي
للجزء الاوسطي من البحر الاسود
هذا الاستهداف ياتي ضمن اطار عام يمكن
القول ان الاستهدافات تكثفت في المرحله
الاخيره وهو ما اعترف به الطرفان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوت تحدث عن انه يقينا
امامه هجوم مضاد اوكراني وايضا اوكرانيا
تحدثت عن ان الهجوم المضاد بعد واقعا في
اطار الهجمات الميدانيه وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت عن صبي ثماني هجمات عند محاور
مختلفه من دونياتك وايضا ثلاث هجمات اخرى
عند عدد من المحاور في مقاطعه القتال
محتدم بشكل كبير خاصه عند محورين اساسيين
او جبهتين اساسيتين في مدينه دنيتك حيث
نتواجد شمالا وجنوبا مارينكا تفصل ايغور
كورشنكوف في الخسائر التي تكبدتها القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذين المحورين من دبابات
ومنعتاد للقوات الاوكرانيه ولكن هناك
تاكيد على ان القوات الروسيه تقوم بصد
جميع الهجمات التي تنفذها القوات
الاوكرانيه وبالتوازي مع ذلك هناك
استهدافات وعمليات هجوميه تقوم بها القوات
الروسيه بدورها في عدد من المناطق